or assimilated Mexicans do they get
antsy about the New Mexicans
oh yeah even even Mexican immigrants
themselves will trash other Mexicans
I am Nicolas be for recent TV and today
we're talking with Gustavo Ariano who
writes the ask of Mexican column for The
OC Weekly and we are and wonderful
beautiful and very formerly white Orange
County California because Szabo thanks
for talking to that's it for having me
you started the column in 2004 and they
asked a Mexican column which where you
answer everybody's questions about
Mexican myths in American culture our
Mexican is better off in the American
imagination now than when you started
the column no actually right now we're
probably we're at a nadir in terms of
American Mexican relations especially
because of this whole illegal
immigration debate especially now that
you have even more Mexican migration
going across the United States as
opposed to the historical center is the
Southwest Chicago some parts of the
Midwest now we're all over the place now
that a conquista is really beyond Aztlan
so now what people are more freaked out
than ever before remember you when do
you take Canada is that supposedly I
heard that that Canada is about to
declare cinco than my own official
holiday we made our inroads in there I
love it well you know as somebody who
likes to celebrate Columbus Day and st.
Patrick's Day I just want to say Cinco
DeMayo is a bridge too far but who's the
most offensive Mexican stereotype in
American popular cultures at Jack Black
and natural Libra is it Anthony Quinn in
any movie or beautiful Viva Zapata
whatever or some a Hayek whatever she's
being so much oh yeah Salma Hayek does
not offend other than her acting skills
but you see her that's not offensive at
all natural Libre is interesting because
you had Jack Black playing a half
Mexican and yet Mexicans we lionize
Anthony Quinn but if you want to play
that game well he was only half Mexican
as well and by the way I have seen La
Strada he's the most unconvincing strong
man since Muammar Qaddafi Quinn with
Quinn was the quintessential ethnic he
played Filipinos he played Zorba the
Greek he played an Italian every once in
a while he played a Mexican too
are we reaching a point then I mean
because you say okay we're at a nadir
because of illegal immigration but are
we are we reaching a point of
assimilation of the mexican-american in
terms of the way the Italians might have
I would tend to think that they crossed
over sometime around the time of the
Godfather pretty much any time a ethnic
identity gets up starts itself
celebrating its gang sternness it seems
like that's the point are we getting
there when you think of Puerto Ricans
they don't even exist anymore
no disciples of exist anymore what
happens is Mexicans have always
assimilated into the United States the
United States for the most part though
has not accepted the fact that Mexicans
assembly you have Mexican I mean you
have to Hahnel have been here since
1700s but don't speak a lick of Spanish
yet very much maintained that they
handle Texan identity myself my parents
my dad was an illegal immigrant my mom
came to this country legally the first
language I spoke was Spanish and here we
are at trading jabs at Anthony Quinn a
quintessential Hollywood heroes so
Mexicans they're always going to
assimilate no matter how much
immigration you have they're always
going to simulate that the issue though
I think that people don't accept or
don't want to understand is that you
always have new waves of Mexicans that
restart those you know ethnic wars like
you had with the Italians and the Jews
and blah blah blah is there a lot of
kind of our assimilated Mexicans do they
get antsy about the new Mexicans
oh yeah even even Mexican immigrants
themselves will trash other Mexicans my
parents are from Zacatecas central
Mexico I call it the Isle of Mexico good
Heartland values legendary for their
work ethic we always badmouth people
from Michoacan which is just a couple
hours south from Mexico
everyone from Mexico trashes people from
Mexico City which is like the New York
City of Mexico and then of course in
Mexico everyone trashes the people from
the southern part Chiapas Oaxaca I get
at all those happen to be the immigrants
are now coming in bigger waves than ever
before speaking of Chiapas is it true
that the protests there kind of burned
out because they only had one ski mask
to go right no I could never really have
a crowd that's not but theses have
obviously the the revolution that they
tried there 94 kind of got capped at the
knees but they've had their autonomous
communities there now ever since but
it's not going anywhere
you know Vicente Fox came out
it's the drug war it's not a good idea
or event I think it's a great idea I
think we should end the drug war there's
billions of dollars spent on both sides
of the borders and drug consumption just
keeps going up up and up well I had the
problem that I have with Fox is why
wasn't he why didn't he say this well
while he was president got a little and
I guarantee you once he's out of office
he's gonna say oh we should have spent
all those monies and how they say a gun
running to our federales to be able to
crack down on this to go back to
assimilation is assimilation the goal
for all immigrants I mean this is you
know a virtue on the left and the right
pretty much okay somehow talk about
assimilation is that what we should be
talking about or should we be trying to
build a glorious mosaic or are these two
things not mutually the melting-pot
versus the solid bull theories of
assimilation people can try to have the
idealized salable in fact that's more
popular among the left nowadays like oh
you know we just have different cultures
but assimilation is inevitable in this
country even if you have a family that
does not want to say my parents my
parents always wanted me to speak
Spanish they wanted me to speak English
too but they wanted me to keep my
Spanish tongue I'm bilingual but I don't
speak the best Spanish if I have
children I want my children to speak
fluent Spanish as well but I know you
spoke very well exactly which means that
they won't eventually what happens in
this country with all immigrants is
what's called symbolic ethnicity a term
popularized by Nathan glazier where
basically you have immigrants like the
Irish the Italians they just celebrate
the aspects of their ethnicity of they
want to but they're no longer ethnics
anymore what is the primary if the
symbolic Irishness has something to do
with a clatter ring or a fisherman
sweater or something like that what is
the what's the best symbolic Mexican
identity going out there the food I mean
it is the food you could be the most
assimilated right-wing Mexican or you
could be the greatest Chicano activist
at the end of the day we have our
Tapatio hot sauce in the fridge our mom
is making us Dorothea sometimes handmade
and every weekend we have to get rid of
our hangover then it's a week menu
though I always thought of menudo as a
puerto rican supergroup but well I think
we're done but so can I see your birth
certificate just not sure sure I am
legal American citizen born in this
country this is impressive because
neither Barack Obama nor Donald Trump
and actually that's something of a
security card I got in there too we've
been talking to Gustavo oriano the ask
of Mexican columnist for who sees weekly
thanks Gustavo yes for a reason TV I'm
Nicolas